it was a dedicated mission to take
technology to the absolute limits and
then destroy it
those guys got to be careful I don't
think we can get much closer to a big
seismic event underwater than this we
were at kavagi a couple years ago and we
found sharks living in the crater of the
volcano which is really wild because
it's one of the most active submarine
volcanoes in the world once you find
that it's like we're in we got we got a
lot more to check out
[Music]
we're going to the volcano to blow up
robots they measure things like water
temperature co2 pH but sometimes it's
just fun to blow stuff up isn't it these
robots are designed to be as simple as
possible which in this case is some used
PVC sewer pipe yeah that was found in
the village and then you just kind of
put some relatively fancy electronics on
to that and whammo you have an
autonomous boat so as we get closer to
Karachi we see things like Barracuda
dogfish tuna rainbow Runner and then
also the Sharks that are swimming in and
out you start asking why they go in
there in the first place
do they sense an eruption and then get
out of there or are they just caught up
in and blown up in the air chances are
not but really it's an open question
Morgan is one of our guides and he's the
highest respected navigator in that
region and we're watching the volcano
and out of nowhere he just kind of
quietly says I'm ready for the big one
within 10 seconds of him saying that a
volcano I'll do the biggest eruption of
the day Morgan somehow this is the bossy
one
robots zero
[Music]
but it's fast on recording can you take
a photo yeah what just happened
well one of the greatest things in
marine science just witnessed the
world's first blowing up of a robots
from a volcano we swooped in to pick up
the robot kind of looks like a mess but
it was a beautiful mess and it collected
samples there's pieces of hot ash there
they're sticking into the robot right
now that was hot melted lava just a few
minutes ago we're going to take these
samples and we're going to give it to
one of the leading submarine
volcanologists in the world and it's
going to be the freshest piece of Earth
he's ever held in his hands you're gonna
get much fresher than that we're in the
midst of a robotic Renaissance the parts
that are required to make robots move
and perceive their environment are
getting cheaper and cheaper and more
accessible that's really when the big
discoveries contracting so it's a very
exciting time to be a roboticist
[Music]